you know I had the luxury of Sons of
Anarchy for seven years when my daughter
was first born so yeah I go to work in
the morning I could come home at night
which was fantastic are you still close
with those guys yeah that's a friendship
that they'll see you know that's not
going anywhere do you still talk to all
the guys all of them all the time all
the time just what a Brotherhood that's
crazy we just got off with Kim I just
got off with coats uh I was texting with
Pearlman I love them
it was like um
it's like we went now we can reflect on
it
like now but it was like we went through
this thing that we were all unsure of at
the end and we just needed to get away
from each other
and then we came back around I I now get
it I I get what a big hit it was I mean
I I didn't really understand the whole
like before Sons Michael I was oh you're
you're the guy from Black Hawk Down oh
you're that guy from open range well
you're the guy on goon glass boys
you're that guy but then you do a show
like Sons for me and the the level of
what I hit that thing was and what crazy
show it was I became Kim Coates so I I
think after watching the shows now that
Theo and I have done I Now understand
the incredible fandom I saw Charlie in
the long goal I see Boone a law I see
chem I see Theo yeah we always bumping
Perlman Pearlman
was he fun to work with he's the best
he's such a sweetheart and he's so he's
such a beautiful human being and
I love these politics and he's so
eloquent I mean he's just he's just he's
just a beautiful man you know Ron I know
him from conventions
he he he's the best he's really cranky
but I love him he's so was he cranky on
set
ah
sure I mean the the first he looks like
he'd be cranky right
but the last couple you know when you
know you're gonna die or you don't like
the writing or yeah he became cranky but
I think we all had a bit of crank in US
yeah I mean it was probably grueling
schedule and a lot of work right
absolute chaos better having no other
way it was
like Charlie and I just said when we did
that Reaper review thing with Kim and I
it was like going to college like for me
you know Michael you you I'm sure you're
the same I I I'm allowed to complain
because I'm old now but I never I never
took for granted how how much we worked
or I never complained yeah it was some
really tough days we we you know we're
all in leather and riding those bikes
and those Harleys and we shot in like
July August September which you know in
La is really really hot and we you know
because this fictional Brotherhood kind
of became this real Brotherhood
and we lived on that [ __ ] set we we
rode our bikes to work in the morning
and then we would on the evening and
then we would ride our bicycle they'll
be smoked cigarettes and they would ride
or motorcycles home and it really I
think like Charlie and I said the other
day I don't think you can ever do that
again it was like a it was like a moment
in time right it doesn't exist anymore
it's like The Sopranos I talked to those
guys and they had a lot of the same
exact kind of deal yeah we kind of lived
uh for for seven years so it was yeah a
lot of what you saw up on the screen
like I was saying earlier you have to
have that camaraderie and everyone has
to be treated equal and and she was up
on the screen I think that's why a lot
of reasons why Sons of Anarchy was a
successful yeah yeah science is one of
the only shows ever that our our ratings
never went down they they only went up
like up and up they never plateaued they
never they just went up from season one
to two all the way so FX is the biggest
hit they ever had by a gazillion dollars
so pretty proud of all that so silly and
the fact that I'm like third on your
Sons of Anarchy list is even more funny
third what do you mean
I know you had Flanagan coats I know you
had these people on seriously I don't
[ __ ] do them and when I do do them I
want them to end immediately it's like
I'll see two words and I go again I
don't want to talk to you anymore leave
me alone why is that I it's always the
same stories and but when you call me I
thought you know the beautiful rose and
Bloom is going to be a laugh Rose and
Bloom and I've had good old Sparkles
because I've already talked to hunt him
he's Banning your show he's already said
it's gonna happen that's it he's done
well there's some big accidents on set
we had three
yeah we had three we got lucky Ronnie
Perlman went down hard and I was right
beside him when I got off my bike like a
horse I just got out so fast told him
not to move not to move lay there lay
there the ambulance came and he turned
out to be all right a lot of lesions and
scrapes and then Mark Boone Jr booney
we could have lost him we were doing a
scene we were chasing the Russians of
course we were chasing the Russians why
wouldn't you be you know who wouldn't be
and so we're chasing the Russians and he
had this old late 90s Harley with these
ape hangers really tall it was really
hard to negotiate and navigate as a
tough bike to ride and he's a great
Rider and we went around a corner too
many rocks and he slid and he slid hard
and he missed a big big boulder and uh
he was up for a couple days and then
Tommy yeah I could go on but we we were
all right no one got seriously hurt we
were very lucky right I love character
actors and I think it's like when I saw
Ron Perlman and Kim Coates and Tommy
Flanagan and Katie Seagal and like and
and I did the original pilot with Scott
Glenn like who I'd done who had done a
movie with prior to that I was
enthralled that was also a giant fan and
a shield so I was like so happy to be
there
um
chaos it was absolute chaos I when I did
Luke Cage right after it I had the same
executive producer writer who was on
that show with me and it was uh also the
showrunner I had done this movie I did
low riders he wrote that I was almost
like um
I Rescue all my dogs and so I know what
it's like I was like a dog who just got
rescued but they were like hey hey it's
okay it's okay they just need you on set
like it's okay because it was like I was
so tense all the time from Suns all the
time was it emotionally or mentally
draining being in Sons of Anarchy it
just looks like a lot of work yes it was
like a heavy show like it was Heavy in
all aspects it was
I I could talk about the positives for
days like I don't know what it's like to
be in the Rolling Stones or the Beatles
or being like a rock band like even a a
minimal one
but like when we were together and we
were together all the time on our bikes
going to Comic Cons going to restaurants
going to bars it was like being rock
stars like you would just roll up 11
deep and everyone was in the show and
people were like what the [ __ ] is
happening here so it was that where it
was like I'd never been exposed to that
it was a guest star actor and then at
the same time it was the schedule of the
amount of we were filming on the budget
we were filming it would be compared to
like a low budget Indie now and we were
filming at a at an accelerated pace
and then the emotions were running so
high
so we would we had no other choices but
to well I know for me and maybe it's
because I'm not nearly as good as an
actor as all the other people I had no
other choice but to exist as that
character all the time
because of the schedule
wow so and Juice was like a really
[ __ ] up character so I was kind of
[ __ ] up for like eight years
really it messed you up for eight years
you were just kind of like not quite
yourself
I tried to turn it off but it was like
we were always all together so our
Dynamic was shaped from the show there
was only three of us that could ride
Mark Boone Jr uh David labrava and
myself of Belize knew how to ride some
of them lied and said they did and then
they fell a few times and realized well
you're a liar so they all had to go to
bike school
um everybody and I would say by the end
of the Seven Seasons Charlie Hunnam
probably became the best Rider because
he was never off his bike he rode to
work every day we all did but he really
did and uh yeah no he became a really
good writer so yeah I know I I knew how
to ride and I I was called Safety First
Michael because I would stop so many
shots I Go Kai
Scott Flanagan why are you rubbing your
[ __ ] feet on the ground because my
boots are slippery will you do that
later ah [ __ ] I don't know I've never
seen it you don't watch it I've never
seen Sons of Anarchy you've never seen
Sons of Anarchy no I I said you did
Seven Seasons I saw bets I've never
watched the whole thing I mean I I'd go
with the premiere and because you know
because she that's what you do it isn't
it but but
begrudgingly I have to ask that because
that's what you do because uh and I
never watched the show because we were
living that like I said earlier we were
loving that [ __ ] so I never really
saw theoroshi calls me in like April May
of 2020 when there's nothing going on
and he goes we should do
Reaper review
and review Sons of Anarchy every single
show and I went no what do you what are
you nuts there was 92 shows seven I'm
not going to do well we've done it we're
actually on the last show which we'll
record next week of two and a half years
of talking once a week that the fans
have gone nuts for it bazooka brains
Bananas off the rails